wo man ich werde nie wieder mit den
älteren normal reden können das hast du
sehr gut erkannt
du wirst glaube ich mit denen gar nicht
mehr reden können du warst glauben jetzt
willkommen beim ein wie ja und zwar
heute haben wir mal so eine sache
ich komme direkt auf den punkt ich habe
euch bei instagram und snapshot gefragt
ja ganz ehrlich mal so von mir zu euch
sind euch schon mal so richtig peinliche
sachen passiert bzw hab ich was richtig
peinlich ist erlebt oder gemacht wenn ja
dann schickt mir das doch einfach mal
wer ins tal direkt da sind dann wirklich
auch ziemlich viele sachen gekommen wie
zum beispiel diese hier
ich habe mal mitten im unterricht meine
tage bekommen und der stuhl war voll zum
glück war es die letzte stunde habe was
ein glück oder zum beispiel auf diese
beichte meine haare sind heute voll so
zepf aussehen wie eine nein das war
nicht die beichte also passt auf ich
weiblich 14 weißt du dass ich und meine
beste freundin weiblich 12 uns
gegenseitig an unserem film saugen und
wir ist nicht gerade sanft machen
sie hat mir dann mal aus versehen den
nippel abgebissen und ich musste sofort
ins krankenhaus in meinen eltern habe
ich gesagt dass ich ihnen der tür
eingeklemmt habe das stelle ich mir so
direkt die frage warum warum ja das
waren zwei von wirklich ziemlich vielen
bereichen von euch die ungefähr so
aussahen und bei einer habe ich so
wirklich gedacht was die wirklich schön
ausgeschmückt schön lang und die trage
ich euch jetzt vor und kommentierte ein
bisschen wenn ihr bock habt ihr zweite
folge dann lasst genau jetzt dort nach
oben da bei ich sag mal 13.000 likes
gibt es immer noch mehrere ausgaben
kommt der nächste woche direkt schon die
nächste ihr können wir auf eure weichen
schicken einfach bei insta direkt ist
kurz die eigentlich wo in star trek das
ab schickt mir eure beichte passiert
natürlich alles ganz anonym ihr werdet
nicht im video mit namen genannt
verspreche euch wir können gerne um 5
millionen euro wetten dass ich anonym
bleibt jetzt fangen wir an mit der
beichte oder wie man es nennen soll und
let's go also leute fangen wir an hallo
alex ich bin weiblich und 16 jahre alt
erst letztens etwas richtig krass es
passiert ich war bei einer freundin in
ihrem neuen haus zu besuch und habe auch
bei ihr übernachtet so weit so gut
hört sich erstmal ganz entspannt an dann
ging es allerdings so langsam los ich
kannte mich in ihrem neuen haus
natürlich 0 aus und habe auch etwas
länger braucht das wc zu finden als ich
halt mal aufs klo musste ja das kenne
ich natürlich erkennt auch jeder von
euch nicht sagen
wohl noch nie was müssen aufs klo kommt
dann erst in das zimmer der eltern dann
in das zimmer der großeltern dann in das
zimmer von bruder und dann die letzte
tür ist erst das klo so kurzer ktm
später dann sagte meine freundin sie
müssten noch duschen und ist dann aus
dem zimmer gegangen hat auch auf die ski
währenddessen habe ich mich im zimmer
noch ein bisschen umgeschaut und habe
das haus gefunden warum auch immer man
die wie etwa die 16 ja gut wenn das
heute mit 16 normal ist will kann seine
habt ihr das hus oder nicht schreibt man
den kommentaren mit eurem alter schreib
mal weiblich schrägstrich euer alter
schrägstrich desto ja oder nein also
müsst ihr natürlich nicht wenn es zu
intim ist oder sowas ist doch da müsst
ihr wissen ich dachte mir ich ziehe sie
an und wenn sie reinkommt werden wir uns
beide kaputtlachen
ich wartete und wartete doch meine
freuen braucht die recht lange
also beschloss ich sie vor der tür ein
bisschen zu verarschen und die tür von
außen aufzusperren und sie zu
erschrecken
also die badezimmertür wo sie halt grad
der macht sind warum ich die dessous an
gelassen habe weiß ich selber nicht so
genau will man also zu der tür gegangen
wo ich dachte dass das das klo wäre und
stellte mich dann leise davor dann
wartest du dich noch einige sekunden und
riss die tür auf es hätte auch gut sein
können dass sie die tür abgeschlossen
hat aber das war im ersten moment nicht
so also kann halt doch sein dass die
abgeschlossen war das weiß ich nicht
weil ich nicht das bad sondern zimmer
der eltern erwischt habe das ist
natürlich schon peinlich genug aber
jetzt kommt wirklich der höhepunkt das
ist ja immer so bei auch so in der
schule so erst geht das los mit
einleitung höhepunkt schluss ich
erwischte also das zimmer der eltern wo
diese sich gerade vergnügten die haben
bestimmt somit zu autos gespielt und so
schlimm also wenn ich das jetzt noch mal
alles in meinem kopf zusammenfasse hat
sie sich dessous angezogen wollte diese
dessous anziehen um sich mit der
freundin kaputt zu machen ist dann aus
dem zimmer rausgegangen um die freundin
zu erschrecken hat dann das zimmer der
eltern erwischt und ist dann mit dem
diskus in das zimmer der eltern
reingesprungen wo diese gerade sex
hatten ach so ja das macht auch dann
sinn um mein gott das ist mir immer noch
so peinlich ich habe mich sofort
umgedreht und eine leise entschuldigung
gestammelt wo man ich werde nie wieder
mit den eltern normal reden können das
hast du sehr gut erkannt
du willst glaube ich mit denen gar nicht
mehr reden können
ob diese jetzt natürlich so 100 prozent
stimmt oder nicht kann ich euch nicht
versichern aber es könnte natürlich sein
deswegen schickt mir eure beichten die
war jetzt wirklich ich fand interessant
dass unterhält mich einfach sowas
durchzulesen ich halte es natürlich auch
anonym
klar manchmal geht man auf das profil
und denkt sich die hat dass du das
gemacht ja ist witzig ansonsten war es
das schon mit diesem video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen am 21 05 kommt mein
3000 abonnenten zum beispiel das ist der
sonntag nächster woche verpasst das auf
keinen fall boni nicht vergessen doch
nicht so verpassten triple instagram
brandy unbedingt so weiter mit dem
letzten video 68 ps und ja wir sehen uns
dann natürlich kommende woche wir sehen
uns sonntag wieder da kommt auch ein
krasses video das hat wahrscheinlich
keiner von euch so erwartet aber es ist
so halt kann man nichts dran ändern seid
gespannt peace